[Music]
that moves on a plane I'll be like I'll
watch Transformers 4 which I wouldn't
watch on land but in the sky I'll do it
are we rolling air or C I'll do it yeah
what do you call it international waters
you know well we're joined by Allison
Brie we're very excited to have you here
here what do you think about my mic
placement that looks pretty good so a
little closer bring it in there you go
and we have uh Steph guest bartending
here today
all right Steph best hair in bed Style
and you guys have a Google search of me
up for me just in case during the
passionate scene from your new movie uh
somebody I used to know and now
streaming on Amazon check it out you got
that right directed by your husband
that's right and co-written by he and I
that's yeah is that awkward it was
awkward no wow I couldn't write anything
with my wife she would just be like that
that line you have sex really yeah I
like my life that line you did you run
[__] buyer though now yeah run bits
buyer but uh we couldn't read a movie
it's tough to work with someone you date
that's that can't be easy well that's
why we're married yeah that's true
that's the only reason we got married
because we were like we gotta work
together yeah but I think it helped my
my wife is also a comic so that it helps
and it hurts you know sure some places
you're like this is great we can talk
comedy you understand the lingo but then
also you're like I could have gotten
that gig Oh no just kidding I don't know
if Dave and I are ever competing for
roles hmm But I'm not going to take it
totally off the table there could have
been yeah it was Jay Ellis who's by the
way [__] hot dude kitten that's a
hobby attractive I was lost in his eyes
oh yeah yeah
was there any point where you're writing
it where you where Dave's like I could
play this guy and then you're like he's
got to be black yeah I was like I would
prefer Jay Ellis
there really never was because I think
you know Dave's directorial debut was
the rental it's a horror movie and I got
to act in that which was awesome and I
feel like he realized on that he didn't
act in it and it was the Saving Grace it
was like when you're directing you just
want to be fully focused on that one
thing and not have to be thinking about
your performance and it slows everything
down having to watch playback and do all
that stuff and I just think that worked
so well that going into this that was
the genetic makeup of it from the start
is like oh now let's write something
together and now recreate that same uh
you know way of where working with him
directing and me right but so he wasn't
going to play the role now Jay is so
much hotter whoa whoa I didn't say
hotter I did not say hotter you know
attractive period could you meet Dave on
a movie or no no Dave and I met at Mardi
Gras oh wow yeah my hometown really yeah
yeah I love New Orleans hell of a town
and Mardi Gras my favorite holiday I
love Mardi Gras I used to go all the
time with my community crew oh yeah went
down there with Danny and Donald and Ken
and Joe Russo that was the first trip
and then we went down the next year uh
with Joe and a couple of my girlfriends
and one of my friends knew Dave we ran
into him at the airport actually on the
way there he was just heading back he
was shooting a movie there
um heading back from like a weekend home
and she invited him to dinner with us
and he came to dinner and then she did a
little setup
so we're at dinner Dave gets to dinner
late he's got a whole other side of the
story where he actually said he couldn't
come to dinner because he had plans all
his plans got canceled when we landed in
in the city for some reason
so he by the time he gets to dinner
we're all drunk and he sits next to my
friend Jules and I'm across the table
and I get a text from her and it's like
you should hook up with Dave whoa and I
was like yep yes please
I was super single I was hooking up and
it was Nola you get crazy what else am I
gonna do this weekend it's like flights
there's no rules in New Orleans exactly
Vegas New Orleans Nashville there's
certain cities
I'll take your word for it
um so I text back enthusiastically
meanwhile across the table she shows the
exchange
she's like points at me that's the gal
like what do you think and he's like
I'm in wow she's like don't tell her
that I showed you this text exchange 10
minutes later she and I get up to go to
the bathroom she's like maybe you and
Dave and I'm like I mean I'm into it I
don't know if he's would be interested
and she's like he's interested I showed
him your text under the table don't tell
him that I told you that I showed him so
we left the restaurant we both had a
sexy secret knew that the other person
was like on board yeah at the next
location I kind of like sidled up to him
at the bar with a beer and I was like
there's Molly in this beer oh I think we
should split the beer and have a great
night together what do you saying holy
[__] and he said yeah wow
this is amazing but with a black guy
what do you think about is Molly what is
that like you never done Molly no I've
never done it hold on
well speaking of drinks let's get some
of these drinks over here and we're
doing remotely and you had to take the
edge off yeah
oh thank you all right all right gracias
mimosas to get our vitamin C in because
we're classy ladies and you're doing a
press tour so you have to stay healthy
I'm trying to stay healthy cheers
12 years so we're down the drain
I'm glad I could be the one to break
that cycle I am on the road with the
sober guy and it annoys me he's my
opener sober and it annoys me and I
because it just bugs me I wanna I have
two other people pure of a lifestyle I
bring a tournament life on track too
much he's married he's got two kids but
it still bugs me and I have a tour
manager will drink with me and I have
James who filmed drinks with me yeah but
I want Gary to drink with me and I asked
him like you've been sober for how long
and he's like it's like a year and I
said if you had one sip it'd be all down
the drain though so I kind of wanted to
trick him into drinking
[Music]
I don't think it's one step if he takes
one sip he's back in the game he's a
little guy so oh wow he's a lightweight
you're just slipping into his sparkling
a little vodka and just half an hour the
sobriety is done that's not that's not
Cosby bad I don't condone it this is how
Matt Lauer started I'm just gonna get a
button it's just a button
so that's a great story though I mean
that's that's that's pretty cool yeah it
was a great 48 Hours let me tell you wow
11 years ago oh wow so ladies you should
hook up the first night because you
never know
[Music]
that's my motto and it worked out there
you go I see that don't you find
sometimes that because that text message
and the hookup and the flirting and the
knowing it's gonna happen is almost
hotter than the actual intercourse yeah
it's like you don't want there to be too
much build up I say you want to kind of
go in for the kill right away and see if
it's gonna work out yeah I agree with
you the consent is hotter than to say
yes I just want to know it's possible
right because I'm in I'll disappoint you
later but ultimately yeah we're good I'm
tired and I want to go to bed right
you're in oh great literally is he doing
the Press tour too or is it he's doing
it he's doing it too we're sort of
dividing and conquering smart smart two
fronts
yeah I've been re-watching Community
just randomly so it's weird that you hit
us you know that your people hit us up
and we're like oh I think I've just been
watching it on the road I need a light I
need a light Road Show yeah it's so good
one such good writing thank you yeah it
holds up I I have recently I recently
rewatched uh some of it because I love
to watch my own work no they you know it
went up on Netflix during covid and I
just rewatched a bunch of it and I loved
it it's great it's full of jokes it's a
great cast it's very edgy too you know I
think like a lot of the writing was
Towing that line for a network comedy
for sure of like getting in some good
Jabs I don't know is there it might have
been the last kind of edgy jokey Punchy
comedy on network yeah well I mean even
like Atlanta is now FX not FX and that's
a different type that's a really
different type yeah that's beautiful
yeah Rachel great show but it was like
the office and 30 Rock and Arrested
Development and
30 Rock it was the office 30 Rock Parks
and Rec and then us that was like the
dream three years or however long that
block was going it was like whoa this is
awesome yeah but but even the office I
feel like had like new life on Netflix
true totally true number one showing
yeah all the Gen z's are like what is
this show yeah I'm discovering it look
what I found you guys got to try taxi
you gotta show like a real old show the
Seinfeld it's a really cool show people
probably discovered I mean I'm honestly
Dave and I have been watching an episode
of Seinfeld every night before we go to
bed just to get it back in our system
and it's so it's the best it's
incredible and you see all these other
shows now doing a lot of their story
lines totally well it's so funny having
not watched Seinfeld in a long long time
and I don't think I ever even saw all
the episodes because you didn't have a
Netflix or somewhere right you would
just catch them whenever they were on
but I've probably I've probably seen all
of Curb Your Enthusiasm which is
obviously amazing and of course Larry
David so then you go back and watch
Seinfeld and you see a lot of the
storylines I know you're like oh the
person who says Happy New Year for too
long like a lot of those little jokes
the best come back around and I love it
it's called Jewish comedy yeah Larry I
was watching a curb yesterday The
Accidental text on purpose on my flight
back ah you hung over you're like thank
God for curb because the selection on
Delta is not that great so interesting
and it must be fun for Gen Z to go back
and be like whoa a gay joke what is this
sorcery holy hell when the office was
chock full of dark stuff yeah some of
it's it's like yeah now it's all the
game of like
did this age well like where are we you
know what it's a dangerous game to play
because it's comedy if it worked yeah it
worked you know and that's how you view
it you view it through the time caps
when you start analyzing that stuff you
go you go nuts all right definitely and
I don't even really ha I can't have
perspective on it because it's stuff
that I loved and watched always totally
right sometimes it's even hard for me to
be like oh okay I guess I understand why
yeah people are finding that offensive
now you know yeah sometimes it is funny
it is funny when you watch uh I was
really hungover a couple weeks ago on a
flight and I was like let me just watch
like something light and I'm seeing a
pattern here super drinking podcast I'm
not judging but do we research it's
called research yeah but I put on that
movie Just Friends and I'm like I feel
like eight of the punch lines are just
you're gay oh my gosh every joke was
just like you're gay that's half of
Apatow too yeah that's why his movies
are so long you gotta get enough of
those skates you gotta edit it in 20
minutes of unedited
we're gonna add them in post I love that
movie Just Friends did you notice well
clearly you've maybe not watched our
movie yet but Julie yeah Julie Haggerty
who plays the mom is the mom yeah she's
great see yourself
[Music]
I love her you have all these great
comedy cameos in this there's you know
Amy Sedaris is in there yeah here's Sam
Richardson yeah are these did you reach
out to them were they yes so we've just
called in a lot of favors especially for
those parts
um Sedaris and I worked together on
BoJack Horseman for years but we never
met in person because she lives here in
New York and we did that show in L.A
that's crazy
you were reading back and forth we did
we always would do table reads together
it was funny because it was like the one
animated show that I've worked on where
they made such a point to do table reads
with all of the actors there except Amy
Sedaris who would call into this like
speakerphone that was in the center of
the table and she was so funny they
would always ask us to do other or like
read all the other characters that they
maybe hadn't cast yet and sometimes we
would also voice some of those side
characters and Sedaris would just do all
these different voices wow but on a
slight delay because she was on a
conference call
um anyway she's so funny and she was so
game to do the movie which was so nice
considering we had never met in person
and she came in half the scene is
improvised by her you know she had a
different button every time she goes to
leave the room I gotta go get my tubes
untied
it was a different joke it was gold you
know you're funny when you're killing on
speaker yeah
that's a tough sell for comedy Strangers
With Candy also it's like the funniest
show I love that show they're up on that
that wasn't Comedy Central was really
chugging along and weird when it was
weird Kids in the Hall yeah that was
like pre-co bear Colbert yeah Blackman
that's just the character yeah
that was fun
animated show that was like drawn
together I don't know the episodes were
short like 15 minute episodes
this is a great story let's just wait
until we figure it out bojack's a great
show to be on too that's an awesome
that's an awesome rage show that was a
great show that was I mean
so many jokes permitted on Bojack and
then still they managed to make it
really dark and deep and it was like
exploring themes of depression yeah
that's a show I can't it's like I
respect the hell out of that show but
it's like a show where it hits me like
Barry where I'm like I can't watch this
[__] before bed this is not your I'm
hungover I'm just gonna flow through
some messages no hope for life right I
loved watching Bojack because also at
the table reads were so funny and then
I'd watch the episode and they would
sneak jokes just into the animation
plays on animals in the background
visual gag yes there was so much going
on it was a great one great so that's
the thing you can do with animation
animation can go so Family Guy says
stuff where I'm like holy moly how did
my power not go out when that joke came
on totally in his animation yeah you can
get away with a lot yeah yeah maybe we
should be like getting away with things
yeah I just farted no one could
[Music]
you know what I I'm glad you said that
actually because I was gonna say what I
love about her comedy and especially
like Strangers With Candy she loves
making herself unattractive yes and
doing roles that are so quirky but she's
super hot super hot sexy fun admire that
she has like a great wig closet you know
she puts like maybe I'll do even doing
this movie she was like I don't know you
guys could I should I have fake teeth we
were like no no we just want you to look
like you yeah but like everything she
always wants to amp it up all right
you're like it's a cartoon baby
yeah she's she's great oh yeah she's
killing Letterman she was so good it was
so funny her Instagram is great too yeah
I gotta I gotta check that out she posts
funny clips and stuff and then I saw a
spread in New York Magazine of her at
her apartment and her apartment's crazy
her Apartments kooky who collects stuff
and does arts and crafts and all things
I think yeah she's like a room full of
old uh sewing machines and you're like
what the hell it's just kooky there
there it is
oh fun nice bookshelf though all right
that's not that just looks kind of
normal but I swear to God coordinated
bookshelf ooh look at that chandelier I
mean it's so cute you couldn't date her
because there's no room there's too many
knickknacks that's true look at that wow
tough to slide some things over in the
bed yeah oh that's great I haven't seen
a TV yet
classy look at that oh my God that is
wild beautiful like a couch like that
spaced out that's yeah look at that
somewhere Wes Anderson just came
um I so the first place I ever saw you
was mad men oh yeah we talk about Mad
Men a lot on this podcast good it's just
a great show and it's a great great
drinking show it makes me want to drink
I mean it's like when you read Hemingway
or Bukowski or something and you're like
I should drink in the afternoon it
really is glamorizing drinking smoking
women yeah I should get a second
yeah those were the days no blacks
joking
just went silent
give a supportive chuckle even and it
really was that clip going around
the uh I mean it really was a like
perfect show and it was just the way
that they would drink I feel like Don
Draper made old-fashioned
cool just even the way he would hold it
like he didn't even care if it slipped
from his hand and broke on the floor
right a delicate touch yeah yeah to that
that hold that air out of place was that
a fun character to play yeah Trudy
Campbell great I mean the show had such
great writing there was so much Nuance
to all the scenes and that was a really
early job for me I think I had done just
like a couple other I did a b horror
movie
um and which is a lot to say about that
it was called Born I played a young gal
who gets impregnated with her um demon
Brothers like demon spawn fetus Mardi
Gras totally it was like it was like I
was at Mardi Gras and then the fetus
possesses her and also kills there's
like a lot of great set piece scenes
like where I have sex with a guy and the
demon fetus like bites off his dick and
he dies
or where this is great PR for abortion I
oh my well I do support them yeah same
we do there's a scene where yesterday I
make out with my I'm just powering
through all right I was powering through
I make out with my roommate who she's
like a phone sex operator wow and then
the demon she kisses down my body to my
pregnant belly and the demon fetus
punches through the center of my
pregnant stomach rips her tongue out of
her head she dies and then I take her
head off and I eat her organs it's
awesome
guys my first job wow Mad Men different
vibe it was slightly different although
I'm pretty sure the the
demon feet is eating the dick scene is
what got me the role on Mad Men
it's a fun reel are you all because you
play a lot of characters like that where
you're not like quite Trudy Campbell
level the Taipei yeah but there's a
little uptightness sure to a lot of the
characters I play I feel like we're sort
of playing with that in this movie yeah
and like the way my character is at the
start of the movie is how everyone
thinks that I am based on the roles that
I play and the way the character is at
the end of the movie is more like how I
really am you're a little looser a
little more chill yeah
um oh and yeah you talk about in the
movie there's a part where you where uh
I don't want to give too much away but
there's a part where one of the
characters says you're not gonna best
friends wedding me so that was like I'm
guessing that's a movie you like I'm
guessing I love it I love it great movie
definitely we pay a lot of homage to my
best friend's wedding in the movie and
we just wanted to be upfront about it
but we were kind of channeling all of
those movies that we love from the 80s
and 90s When Harry Met Sally Sleepless
in Seattle When Harry Met Sally
is a real go-to airplane movie for me
we love her so I just actually watched
it recently on an airplane it's a great
airplane movie
my other favorite airplane movie The
Departed me too it's so weird I love
watching that interesting anytime Alec
Baldwin pops on screen
Wahlberg so much yeah the whole opening
and then it cuts into that song yeah
I remember seeing that with my dad and
he he couldn't tell Leonardo Dicaprio
and Matt Damon apart
you're really movie for him it was an
Inception for him right that's too many
Irish people that's another good plain
movie I don't mind Inception on a plane
the way Matt Nolan intended yeah Chris
oh sorry Chris Matt Nolan oh Matt Nolan
is a friend of Dave's from college that
we name check in the movie Matt Nolan we
put a lot of our friends names we just
named every random character like one of
our friends names in the movie so that's
really fun that's fun for them shout out
to Matt Nolan yeah Matt great director
yeah one of my favorite directors of all
time can't wait for Oppenheimer is uh I
I do want to see that oh yeah me too
guys in all seriousness
exactly Rita Robert Moses the power
broker let me pick it up 2 000 Pages
Jesus Christ that's the kind of book
where I'm like I'll see the movie yeah
to see the movie yeah I'll Wikipedia
yeah can we get a doc right a doc makes
it easy
I could listen to in my car
yeah I am listening to this podcast
called Founders gotta give a shout it's
amazing because it just goes you know uh
Coco Chanel how she made it uh Andrew
Carnegie whatever and the amount of bad
parenting that leads to success is
really a through line yeah we have good
parents
I've met your parents yeah people nice
people very nice but yeah the molestings
yeah I'm still hurts but it seems like
they worked out for you yeah that's true
they knew what they were doing goodness
unwrinkled shirt but yeah nice people
good people but yeah I'm sure
Oppenheimer was diddled that's my point
yeah no do you look at like Howard I'm
just gonna sit with him
we'll have a good silence uh breakdown
of this how dare you uh Oprah Tyler
Perry I mean the list goes off yeah a
lot a lot of bad childhoods oh yeah
anytime you see a biopic you're like
[__] man I know why is that so why is
that always I just watched the Pamela
one oh I haven't watched that yet yeah
yeah I could tell it's gonna be dark and
that's why it's before bed I can't do
the before bed dark yeah I've been I've
been going light yeah she's having a
nice little Resurgence which is nice
yeah oh yeah I'm excited to see that
it's fun watch it for sure well done are
you ROM is rom-com like your top genre
for film I it this is gonna sound crazy
but it's it's rom-com and horror I think
are right at the top for Dave and I both
and it's like he has always liked
rom-coms but I feel like more and more
I've brought him around on the rom-com
side and he is like a horror fiend and
has brought me around and I mean when I
was a teenager I loved horror movies and
some of my favorite all-time films are
horror Thrillers like The Shining
Rosemary's baby
um
I was about to say Sleepless in Seattle
here's the guy on the radio stalks him
hires a private eye like watches him
outside his house
um Silence of the Lambs great oh one of
the best it was on TV that's why I love
cable by the way because I I stopped
having cable for years and I was like
let me just get cable again I'm into
cable my brother's over and I was like
let's watch the last three scenes of
Silence of the Lambs great three scenes
the other day I'm flipping channels
Terminator two I love that I was just
like well Doug I'm gonna settle in yeah
I know what I'm doing this afternoon
there's a couple you got to leave it
just leave it on like Shawshank Casino
you know casino is like a three-hour
violence casino and Goodfellas are both
on that list yeah oh [__] they're doing
the winner through the restaurant
younger than me so I had to uh I
remember we saw the Irishman she she
just had never seen uh Robert De Niro
act in a movie Jake is that the guy from
Dirty you saw the intern yeah I mean no
but she she uh she saw she'd never seen
Goodfellas or Casino so we said that the
uh she also just wasn't a big film
person her dad was super strict growing
up sounds great
well it didn't work out but the point is
the point is uh she saw that first and
then you go back and you watch
Goodfellas and then you watch casino and
she was like all these movies are the
same
not true but that was a takeaway I mean
I
I feel for her that she started with
Irishman because then it took away from
experience on the other two the casino
he's a Jew that's different that's true
that's really different that's a stretch
well the stretch was an Ironman Irishman
we tried to kick that guy I remember
that scene oh that was rough the Jesse
Smollett tape was more realistic than
that with the with the Aging they
couldn't get you can't get a younger
actor that thing was weird they were
talking about how much money it cost and
I was like well it didn't work I know
you should spend a little more yeah like
I guess people want that star power you
know you want the De Niro name on the
poster yeah I don't want to see some
young actor
playing young De Niro that's [__]
yes although
you know who could have done it really
well Shia LaBeouf the guy who went to
prison the kid he played his kid in
Bronx Tale oh yeah he went to he was on
The Sopranos too you know what I'm
talking you know I know who you're
talking about various Italian uh Bronx
so it kind of looks a little
um he looks dineroy yeah yeah but he's
maybe even too old Lilo brancato what
did he go to jail for I think he killed
someone he's Colombian wait real tale
yeah oh geez but like what did they do
you know what I mean
it's a good question yeah good point
yeah sorry what was he wearing I love
again this side now you guys did the
silence on me and it doesn't feel good
it doesn't feel good but wait he's not
Italian isn't that uh attempting to
break into a home it sounds accidental
Oh I thought he killed someone I feel
well yeah he did but but it was actually
so definitely
you know it's like when LL Cool J beat
that guy up for breaking into his house
you don't need that imagine breaking
into someone's house and it's LL Cool J
yeah
yeah and he beat him up oh that's
awesome it was awesome yeah that must
suck when you're just like I'm gonna get
my ass kicked by a famous dude I know I
should have broke into Woody Allen's
house I could have taken him
ll's from Queens yeah you don't want to
mess with the ladies love cool James oh
yeah he's an attractive fellow he is a
hot guy
one time years ago probably 20 years ago
I was so young and it was still like
where you could be late for a flight and
like run through the airport and make it
on your flight those were the days ran
onto the plane I was like the last
person to get on like Catch My Breath
look and the first person I see Sitting
In First Class is LL Cool J and you know
how sometimes when you see famous people
you think it's just a person you know
because you're so familiar with their
face yeah and I just was like Hey Oh my
God good to see you and his it was just
a deadpan straight face didn't say a
word it took me a beat and then I was
like I said Ella
excuse me he's like did I bang her in
88.
I I did that to Katherine Kino once on a
flight really yeah I opened the door I
opened the door and she was right there
and I go I love you and she was like ah
I'm sorry
I got like a get to your seat so we can
take off kind of face
yeah it didn't work out well yeah for me
so Warren Beatty and Annette Benning on
a flight wow
like a married bicker and it was fun to
watch that's cool that's an onset
meeting right Bugsy isn't that where is
that right I think so is that true the
net bending stars in my all-time
favorite movie and all-time favorite
rom-com what is that the American
president
um her it's Michael Douglas it's written
by Aaron Sorkin oh yeah it's directed by
Rob Reiner wow it's so good Michael J
fox excellent okay Martin Sheen not
playing the president this is like an
Aaron Sorkin Martin Sheen pre The West
Wing where he's playing the right to
Michael Douglas's president you've never
seen it they do that dance she's in a
beautiful strapless blue dress she's a
she's a hot lady oh yeah I remember
seeing the grifters my mom with my mom
full frontal full frontal I didn't get
to see him I had to rewatch it because
did your parents when I was a kid they
would just go oh they'd go stand in
front of the TV their bodies like they
wanted to watch the nudity but we
couldn't see it they blocked the TV and
then we would they'd come sit down and
then we would watch like eight guys get
their faces shot off I know like the
standard was weird yeah that's like
don't don't see somebody's butt you
might see somebody's butt while they're
making out but now you're gonna watch
this person's throat get slit like
that's true grippers is dark HBO in the
90s yeah I would say the same with a
Survivor you know they're like climbing
up a rope and you can see like butt
cheek getting blurred but then they'll
eat you know dick uh from a bowl or
something or like Fear Factor it's weird
that we're allowed to eat watch this
horrific guy puking up his guts but like
his under boob that'll that'll ruin you
either way though you're numb I mean
you're just at a certain I think you
should let the kids watch the tits
because that way they'll be numb too and
it won't mean anything yes it's like why
are we so afraid of the human body
you're not I mean I was not I was not
expecting that thank you I love a little
non-sexual nudity yeah sure I love to
watch it and I like to participate in it
yeah here enough cheers otherwise to an
unexpected Bush
it's a fake Bush I hate to tell you all
right it's a merkin guys when I was
working on glow I lasered off so much of
my pubic hair because we wore these
really high cut leotards is this the
kind of content you're using yeah
actually yes
Stephanie's pants so now I have to wear
a merkin because there are laws about
like not showing labia unscrew we didn't
want the movie to be rated
um NC-17 sure like I wear my little
Merck in
um I've worn that same Merkin in a
couple films now it's reusable maybe I
think two and we're out I don't know if
I can do more than two more movies with
the same Merkin which if in case people
don't know it's it's a pubic wig yes
ladies and gentlemen America the
Magnificent to
to groom it um do you have a little pick
yeah I get my little pick out a little
hairspray yeah Dave's like your
American's in the sink again yeah
um never realized how much uh Sorkin
sounds like Merkin
I can hear it yeah it's working man he's
a he's a beast yeah yeah a lot of great
stuff excellent it was a big president
uh remember Uh Kevin Klein was in a
president Dave Dave
that's another great great movie by the
way yeah does playing movie mean it's
slightly worse no it actually to me
doesn't it feels like it's kind of a
comfort sweet spot like The Departed is
a great I love the department I'm
honestly listing most of my favorite
movies but Dave is the kind of movie
that I could watch again and again oh
yeah Sigourney Weaver as the first lady
yeah the 90s we we still liked polish
even right men you guys oh it's true but
now you go back and watch all these
movies the American president this even
The West Wing yeah it's like an Amazing
Fantasy show yes yes of a better world
we talked about Air Force One last week
of the week before where you're like
that was when you rooted for the
president yeah totally I was like you
can't make a movie where Biden's just
[__] up terrorists yeah you'd be like
whatever dude I mean
a [__] you've watched about two
killed situation yeah
I want to see the one where Hunter is
taken down
give us your laptop [__] you Terrace
yeah that's fun Ian McKellen is Joba
Kamala kicking ass
yeah that would be fun
I love Dave so he plays a president
impersonator and then the president has
like a heart attack while having an
affair with Laura Linney whoa a great
crucial cameo in the movie and while
he's under like the powers that be are
like we'll bring in this look alike so
that we can control the government but
in the meantime he like ree falls in
love with the president's wife played by
Sigourney Weaver and he does a lot of
good for the country wow there you go so
there you go Kevin Kline solid actor
that was you're like an info button that
was amazing anything that was on HBO in
the 90s like I have a real encyclopedia
what are the other ones what other top
Allison Bruce I think about like
Defending Your Life oh Grace
you hate it no I've never seen it I love
it it's so a high concept and creative
it's very grounded consider during like
when you tell people the premise which
is 97 when you die you go to this place
it's like limbo it's like a holding Port
before you would go to heaven or
wherever or go back to earth right and
you have to go through like a trial
where they show clips from your life and
you have like an attorney and they
decide whether you'll go on to heaven or
if you have to go back to Earth and do
it again yeah and these two fall in love
but it's like Albert Brooks of course
was like a really shitty person so all
the clips from his life are like of him
like falling off a roof or like you know
they're just all doing like not the best
of things right Meryl Streep is like
saving her kids from a burning building
and stuff like that it's very sweet
great movie really it's a great movie
I've heard a lot about it Rip Torn plays
his attorney yeah it's really funny oh
yeah man I gotta re-watch it he had a
cut what was that woman about the road
trip in the RV
it's incredible it's just so many great
jokes I think he was like an ad man and
he hates you know having a cubicle and
being in an office and he said I'm gonna
travel the world we love to quote Rip
Torn
um Larry Sanders from the Larry Sanders
show gives a great read of a tough titty
that is like my favorite Rip Torn quote
yeah he's incredible my favorite one of
my favorite rip twin quotes from that
show is uh when uh Larry Sanders finds
out that Alec Baldwin [__] his ex-wife
and he's on the show and he's like I
can't interview him I I just having
these images of him [__] my wife and
the worst part is she's on top and
ripped one goes lazy bastard
he said he's he's got his back no matter
what matter what I want that is a
perfect show that's a great free watch
oh yeah I've rewatched it probably five
times every episode and the people who
pass through are incredible also hey now
Stiller Garofalo oh yeah oh Jon Stewart
yeah summer playing themselves and some
are just playing like office writers and
interns Sharon Stone yeah I wonder who
wrote that episode by the way I get to
bang Sharon it's gonna happen yeah
that show needs a pickup I feel like
it's not a sub Network
Oh you mean just to put those episodes I
thought you meant like a reboot and I
was like no we're missing a pivotal
element yeah yeah good point I don't
think yeah well it's probably got to be
on HBO Max right
okay oh they removed it holy [__] I just
saw it on YouTube I rewatched it on
YouTube because I'm such a fan no it's
on HBO okay HBO Max yeah yeah
we've got the Larry Sanders Show all
episodes of Sex in the City including
the two movies is that are you big Sex
in the City person huge sex the original
show was incredible I didn't love the
the later the movies went to Rye and the
reboot
you know I don't wanna look I love them
I'll watch it all I watch it all I
watched all the reboot I'm in here I'm
down for the season I watched it I'm
married but it's not quite the same I I
still love to go back and watch the old
original episodes which
talk about aging they don't all age well
but what I find amazing about I think
all the women look beautiful oh
okay how dare
that's not what I meant
it wasn't in the last decision but the
jokes that show in one monologue will
have like the cringiest line that like
doesn't update well and it will be
followed by like a really prescient you
know what I mean there's like an episode
where Carrie dates a bisexual whoa and
the whole episode is like oh my God I
mean he's bisexual and I said I was okay
with it and her friends being like why
you're okay with it and it's like
there's lines like that but then she'll
do some monologue that's like
what even is gender like won't there
come a point where we don't even need
gender at all and you're like wow Sex in
the City ahead of your time yeah and
then five minutes later she's like oh my
God they want me to kiss a girl
that was a pretty good carry right there
thanks I was only I was half-assing it I
could do a bedroom but I won't
since I like to tease you I love that
show nothing but love for that show
great that's a great show I remember
seeing uh Christian Davis in a coffee
shop I was in seventh grade and I
watched a show because I was like oh my
God this is like New York it's like
shocking I remember I was with my
basketball team we just see her in a
diner and I was like I've seen your show
a bunch and she goes you're too young to
watch I said oh yeah then how come I
know your husband can't get hard yeah
and I got everyone to die in a big laugh
in the diner and she goes all right I
respect that wow I proved myself yeah a
little rap scallion you were
[__] I told it right too or yeah it's
pretty cool and then the waiter came up
and said your credit card decline
they said sir it's 18 or older in here
yeah to go home to your mommy what are
some other Allison Brie Rex like top
movies shows like stuff I mean I love
that you love Larry Sanders
I love the show Dave on FX
yeah our friend is on there yeah
santinos
[Music]
yes I he was in a movie I was in The
Disaster Artist that my husband Dave was
in as well hello Mark yeah great story
Mark
um the guy who shoots Dave the
cinematographer shot our movie tie in it
yeah see her movie
um it's on Prime Somebody That I Used to
Know on Amazon Prime right now that's
right on Friday it goes up on Friday
well no it'll be out but oh out now
right now watch it now what else do I
love are you watching Last of Us yes we
are oh I love it but we're behind don't
okay we've been traveling so we've only
watched the first couple episodes but
have you seen three no oh it's breaking
the internet are you watching this all
right I mean I did read that people had
a problem with the landscape wow or
something a couple things the the the uh
the admirate the the praise is more than
the oh good okay good good good good I'm
loving it love that obviously we loved
White Lotus sure
um you gotta watch these shows if you're
single I mean that's all you can talk
about on dates I know I know I get that
if it's I mean I went on a date the
other night and a woman took out four
vape pens on the table four four was she
sharing like yeah she was like try these
it was like a white trash wine taste and
it was kind of fun this honestly sounds
like a great day it's kind of fun were
they like weed vape pens no oh never
mind no it was like it was like Menthol
lemon oh this is weird banana
but it is actually yeah that's kind of
fun it's very sharing spit [__] after
it was like the Preamble no I went for
it and I got I got Chic and here's the
[__] up I think after sharing Vape it
gets worse
I got cheek and a little bit of butter
that's a vape
but uh yeah a lot like a vape eating Bud
yeah sober disgusting but after a few
drinks yeah not so bad it doesn't do so
bad we can't do it on a plane
so it wasn't like the wet Hot American
Summer piece of gum that means like as
soon as it touches your mouth you're
gonna just make out no you don't you
know what this is the weirdest part she
kept telling me that I felt like she was
[__] with me because the whole time
she was like I don't respect men that
don't like just go for it that was it
went like a dead eye contact like
I don't respect men that don't just go
for it I put my consent forms in my
pocket for a kiss and she fully cheeked
cheeked me you went for it but then said
let's do it again Monday I was like what
get blue balls what the [__] yeah I
didn't say that it was lovely you said
absolutely that's the worst Vape flavor
blue ball
damn that's tough it was weird but now
you're probably gonna see her again nah
all right whoa did she have a vape
holster it wasn't like an amazing day to
begin with there were other problems
yeah
the four geez when did this turn into my
therapy session I'm sorry I didn't know
you were a vape apology she wasn't you
know meeting your needs in in an
emotional way I'm never home anyway so
it's like it doesn't make sense to I'm
home like two days a week and then when
I'm home I'm just like the date is a
risk when you're home two nights a week
and you go on a date one of those nights
and if it's bad if it's a bad date
you're like I just lost half the week
good point home you lost eight hours you
can tell that you're not really in the
space so you're not open to it I'm open
to it don't listen to Allison Brie I'm
open to it
when you know when you meet the girl
that you like then it'll be worth it
yeah yeah I want to make that time I
think that's true yeah the sound this
makes me sound more attainable so I
think the unattainable rather there you
go this is good she's so busy but like
if you're the right one I just don't
have any time are you addicted to vaping
now I'm addicted dude well you smoke
cigarettes no I don't when I'm drunk I
do sometimes me too no not really smoke
when they're drunk or when they're in
Paris exactly oh there you go yeah good
point we're on a plane it's totally in
the bathroom yeah quick one hey folks
it's hard to keep up with a supplement
routine that comes with a bunch of
different products I hate it just start
with one ag1 by athletic greens it's the
morning jump start you need just scoop
shake and have a long side your morning
coffee I'm hooked I drink it every day I
know you're hooked dude you we I got
extra and I take it on the road this
stuff's keeping me from getting sick on
the road same it's tons of vitamins as I
throw a bunch of packets in my suitcase
75 vitamins and minerals and a major
boost to your gut mood energy skin hair
and nails ag-1 gives you increased
energy and mood support making it easy
to live your best life if you're looking
for an easier way to take supplements
athletic greens is giving you a free
one-year supply of vitamin D and five
travel packs with your first purchase go
to athletic greens one word.com slash
drunk that's athletic greens.com slash
drunk check it out
bad habits can follow us through life
fume is on a mission to help you break
those bad habits fume isn't a vape so
it's not filled with the harmful
chemicals that come along with them fume
is a natural diffusive device that uses
plants like cinnamon and peppermint to
help you trade out your negative habit
for a positive one love fume gotta get
on it I hit that puppy at the house
every now and then after a long day the
flavors are great they got all kinds of
fun stuff fume's new version version 2
has an adjustable airflow dial and a
magnetic end cap you always have
something to do with those busy hands
whoa
the easiest way to stop a bad habit is
to switch to a positive when fume is
designed perfectly to do just that it's
fumes goal to make switching easy and
even enjoyable they have thousands of
five star reviews from people just like
you who've successfully switched when
other Solutions just didn't work head to
try ah [__] head to trifum.com and use
code drunk to save 10 percent off when
you get the journey pack today the
journey pack comes with three unique
flavors and the new version 2 fume to
help kick-start your positive habits
that's try fum.com and use code drunk to
save an additional 10 off your first
order today
you can't afford to waste a day stuck on
the cash because of a few drinks the
night before
zebiotics is the answer we've all been
looking for zebiotics pre-alcoholic
probiotic is the world's first
genetically engineered probiotic look at
this stuff this is yeah this is the
stuff right here that's the real deal
this is good stuff it was invented by
PhD scientists to tackle through rough
mornings after drinking here's how it
works when you drink alcohol gets
converted into a toxic byproduct in the
gut it's this byproduct not dehydration
that's to blame for your rough next day
zebiotics produces an enzyme to break
this byproduct down it's designed to
work like your liver but in your gut
where you need it most drink zbiotics
before drinking alcohol drink
responsibly and get a good night's sleep
to feel your best tomorrow gives like
zibiotics a try for yourself try it
tonight go to zebiotics.com drunk to get
15 off your first order when you use
drunk at checkout zebiotics is backed
with 100 money back guarantee so if
you're unsatisfied for any reason
they'll refund your money no questions
asked remember to head to zebiotics.com
drunk and use a code drunk at checkout
for 15 off thank you zebiotics for
sponsoring this episode where I've tried
this stuff it really does work it's good
stuff my buddy Sammy koppelman turned me
on to this and uh gave it to me and
ain't cheap but they work yeah and how
much is your day worth to you good point
and with this promo code little less so
here here I was actually at a restaurant
in TriBeCa with my lady and a woman came
up to me goes you do that drunk podcast
you gotta try Z and I was like all right
beat it yahoo Kook and look here we are
so there you go
when my cat's healthy they're happy and
that makes me happy I got a big old fat
Maine [__] and that thing shits like a
rhino
so you got to have your pretty litter
all right thank God Neil's not here but
I don't always know when they're healthy
pretty litter changes colors to help
detect early signs of potential illness
in my cat including urinary tract
infections and kidney issues
I really use this stuff I swear to God
I'm gonna get a handy later when I pull
up with this uh big bag of litter
because uh my lady loves us though we
tried all these different ones this is
the one your cat's annoyed your cat's
anti-semitic the colors change it's
great pretty little super light crystals
base also minimizes mess and does plus
the crystals last up to a month which
means less scooping and fewer trips of
the garbage can Pretty Little Ships free
to my door and a small lightweight bag I
never run out of it and I don't have a
container of litter taking up space and
stinking up the joint
pretty litter helps keep my cat healthy
and keeps odors down you and your cat
are going to love pretty litter as much
as we do go to prettylitter.com drunk to
save 20 off your first order that's
pretty litter.com trunk to save 20
pretty letter.com drunk this is the best
litter you seem risky I mean you you're
nude in movies that's risky yeah that's
based on my life too because I used to
love to streak in college really in my
adult life and last week at the hotel
before the person we met you at the
wrong time I know what the hell
now it's on camera you can enjoy it
anytime on Amazon Prime
I'm streaked in college that's exciting
well I went to an art school Cal arts
and clothing was optional everywhere but
the cafeteria
so you so what nudity was very much
encouraged and supported whoa art yeah
people say it's not like kids were going
to class naked all the time sure but
they were naked kids in every class no
but there was at all of like
um the school functions that is a really
small school and there's kind of one
main building and at all of the
functions that took place in the main
building there was always the naked guy
who came in shoes and a necklace
he came and he also attended the party
wow that was the principle
well there was that guy mostly people
naked at the pool and it wouldn't be
uncommon to see people
you know it was an art school and I
think they just wanted everybody to have
that artistic Freedom it was not
uncommon to see
like between classes you'd walk past
somebody doing some art installation
where they're nude and like painting
their body in chocolate or body pain
right right so I like to run around and
streak and I like I thought it was funny
made my friends laugh also we had like a
very risque Halloween party oh I bet
where people would go naked and body
paint or like it you know my first year
my freshman year I was a sheriff so I
wore a cowboy hat cowboy boots little
like frilly underwear and some Sheriff
Stars taped to my nipples a complete
costume we got to go back to vaping
all that in the movies
it's the Mimosa I have a share of fetish
oh I didn't even realize yeah yeah you
play an Eric Clapton song I don't get
hard truly just Burt Reynolds yeah yeah
I did have a mustache too so I'm not
into that it wasn't that natural I love
Greek women but uh yeah I was Woody for
uh Halloween one year the um Toy Story
oh cool
oh yeah that's right and you were Buzz I
think I was wondering oh you were Woody
yeah so we know what it's like to dress
up a story
we showed some balls yeah cool story
because you're getting nagged by Allison
Brie what the hell yeah
all right guys other movies we like I
like this Tarantino like I feel like I
always re-watch now that once upon a
time in Hollywood is on cable a lot I've
been watching that that's another one in
the rotation a couple years I like to go
back through the full Tarantino catalog
oh yeah and just watch them all in order
excellent I still love hateful eight I
know it gets a lot that's the one I have
bad love what you've never seen
it's long I saw it in the theater and
they did like a full like a real
intermission or music played and we all
went and like got a snack and that
helped like oh yeah I think I liked it
much more because we actually all got to
like go pee gets refresh our popcorn and
candy and then come back for the back
half yeah I think a pee break is
necessary some of these movies well
these days these three hour movies go up
on Netflix I'm like who's watching this
straight oh my God I'm watching it over
the course of multiple nights do you
still go to the movie theater yes good
all right I do too but I don't have a
problem with movies going straight to
streaming case in points Somebody I Used
to Know comedies don't hit in the
theaters anymore well it's a shame yeah
at the box office I guess they don't and
it's a bummer because comedy and horror
not to bring it back to my two favorite
genres are the best to see with an
audience right and of course like I've
been Dave and I have been traveling
around and watching this movie in some
theaters and it's so fun to hear
everybody laugh and even during like the
serious moments right to hear people
give like a
um
oh no it's really fun and horror movies
we just saw
maybe the last horror movie I saw in the
theater was Barbarian oh that was so
good so good that was so fun to see in
the theater because everybody it just
makes it more fun it honestly makes it I
think slightly less scary yes because
you're along for the ride with the whole
audience of like you're not like
watching it at home like barbarian's
gonna get me yeah barbarian's coming out
of the closet right right and uh I
watched that with a big group and when
the have you seen it yeah I don't give
too much away but when her jugs came out
everybody was like what it was like a
collective huh what do you where would
you rank like her jugs compared to my
jugs this is good well if we're doing
like a jug off I would say hers are a
little more
longer sure yeah hers are longer okay
good but good review of mine yeah you're
you're not so long you're doing great
yeah I have no basis for comparison but
I thought they looked excellent thank
you yeah great you guys yeah so if I
wasn't gay yeah you know thank you the
movie theater is so I don't go enough
and I gotta I gotta get back into it
yeah
I just saw the Banshees of initiary with
my mom in the theater and that was like
a good theater watch because there's
like a lot of discomfort I like there's
it's a good one to see
uh it's a funny movie I mean it's dark
as hell but it is and it's beautifully
shot which is why it's fun to see on a
big on a big screen yeah I once saw um
the movie Unfaithful starring Diana I've
seen it a bunch of times selected Parts
Only the first time that is a hot movie
yeah oh my God what's that guy's name
the hot is it Hispanic guy
sorry keep going what is his name I know
it something else he's so good
um oh Olivier Martinez oh yeah he may be
French oh yeah maybe he's got he's got
stuff yeah there's a lot going on yeah
um the first time I saw that in the
theater I saw it in the theater with my
dad oh no so I couldn't fully enjoy it
and I don't know how that happened were
you sitting on his lap too Jesus Christ
that's brutal right it wasn't my birth
dad it was like my dad
my daddy
yeah he did full penetration during the
movie it was great
that's always a hot movie hot movie is
so hot when he [__] her on the
stairwell I know am I allowed to say
yeah f word
oh in the bathroom stairwell oh the
bathroom is great but the stairwell is
my favorite one because he pulls down
her jeans just enough right not too low
that ass is popping uh it was Merkin
level yeah it's just under the Merkin
pull it up I mean I really I I but I
like it because of the performances
yeah yeah the character I saw species in
the theater with my mom
now we can relate yeah that's like all
have you you've seen that oh yeah it's
all been a long time it's a silly movie
Michael Matson Natasha Henstridge yeah
but it's just it's a lot of full frontal
because she's just like I must be like
check out the specimen yes yes exactly
it was uh I made my mom see uh Exit
Wounds with me and I feel horrible
it's Steven Seagal and DMX
and let me just say DMX for being open
to that he blows them off he blows Segal
off the screen so DMX had some that I
believe oh yeah it's such a bad movie
that it's good it's one of those like
over-the-top pieces of [__] sure I saw
um brown bunny in the theater with my
mom just kidding
we watched two girls one cup
yeah
oh wow Brown buddy that's a good pull
Gallo thank you oh yeah Chloe seven
years oh yeah she's fun yeah oh yeah
great her in the test
yeah I put them in the same kind of fun
weird blonde girl they've worked
together I feel like they're close
friends too and they're also like
like
early Arts icons yeah you know yeah
remember slums of Beverly Hills So Good
nude full uh boobs oh good boobs and
Bush no but I don't think there was a
bush okay just saying that was what you
did as a kid you would just try to find
which one's had yeah it was pre-internet
porn I mean Wild Things was big wow I
mean come on that was shocking come on
and then Kevin Bacon was that his real
dong at the end I hope so because it was
not perfect so I think they wouldn't
have a face I think it was perfect I
didn't think it was like him it wasn't
perfect but I'll be damned if it doesn't
get the job done yeah I'm on board yeah
I'd high five them yeah
a lot of confidence there yeah you can't
write yourself into a dick scene that's
pretty weird yeah yeah it's confident
it's Chris Evans too I feel like that
was leaked oh I don't know that I'm not
familiar with this oh he's got a
beautiful pull it up hanger
oh wow Jason Siegel could have done a
sit up there Siegel you know I know
you're happy he's focusing on the wrong
thing yeah but hey he's doing great he's
sober that movie is a great but that's a
great rom-com great Sarah Marshall yeah
that one's so good so funny so funny
what year was that because that was kind
of it's like oh seven or so yeah oh wow
2013 is when things kind of stop comedy
it bums me out the comedies don't do
well like they used to I mean I feel
like a lot of those people who would pay
to see comedy movies are now just like
I'll go see stand up or I'll go see
something yeah thank God for that that's
great if everybody wants to watch Comedy
at home yes and it's then it's cyclical
because it's like then the studios don't
want to put as much money into the
comedy right so all the comedies become
more Indie comedies which is great but
that's why then they get sold to
streamers it's like this keeps going but
I do miss a big comedy like The Hangover
well but the reason they were big is
right because they had those budgets yes
and they could really like blow [__] up
and make them look big and expensive
totally yeah totally yeah you're right
but they've had to go independent but
yeah I see [__] on Tick Tock or I'm like
this is funnier than anything I've seen
in a movie theater in 10 years I think
that's why yeah Tick Tock and YouTube
and people can watch funny get and and
people's attention spans they're like
I'm laughing so hard watching this two
minute video right 30 second 15 second
video that they don't want to go see it
but it's a bummer it's a bummer comedy
movies man we're watching Something
About Mary on the on the tour bus we
were like and we were we were howling we
were we pick we picked movies we were
like oh you haven't seen this movie yet
my friend James has never seen something
about me crazy so we watch it and
watching him howl at like I mean the
scene where he's just beating the [__]
out of the dog oh my God that was insane
to go that big and yeah and you just
[__] nail it the commitment talk
about also saggy boobies yeah there's a
great binocular mislead where he thinks
he's gonna see switches to the heavier
binoculars as Cameron Diaz has changed
yeah sure but he comes up on the
neighbor yes yeah Magda great Magda oh
yeah that's great Brothers is a good
recipe for a big comedy yeah yeah yeah
Matt Dillon stole that for me oh my God
the teeth alone
we watched the extended version uh
because my friend I had it on DVD but I
couldn't find it so he downloaded uh it
illegally and it was an Extended Cut
what's in the extended version
everything they should have cut it was
weird oh wow like you're like I do not
so they should appreciate having this
stuff in no but there was there was one
scene that they cut where you see some
of them in the credits you know where
you're like what's that right there sure
that [__] they cut so there's one with
Matt Dillon on the date with Cameron
Diaz he walks her to the door and he
goes can I touch your boobs and she goes
okay and it's just him squeezing her
boobs it falls so flat Matt Dylan on the
day like could I do a little improv in
the scene I'm gonna improv something
okay will you get a yes and it Cameron
are you in right right yeah it's it
usually is that way right whenever you
watch the Extended Cut or something like
that and you're like yeah I see why
there's a reason this stuff made that
whoever whoever edited this I'm like
they [__] knew what they were doing
yeah right right I found the good stuff
well I'm such a Seinfeld psycho nut that
I want I have the DVD box set thing that
came out and they have all the deleted
scenes and they're all horrible are they
so bad which you're like oh it's weird
seeing you're like oh these guys are
human even the Seinfeld deleted scene is
bad and again yeah you're like maybe we
shouldn't put the deleted scene
as I say that I'm like there's a couple
scenes in this movie and the last movie
that I like wrote and produced some a
couple of my favorite scenes that we
ended up having to cut just for time not
because they weren't playing well or
anything but it was more just like story
wise it didn't make sense like in this
movie we ended up cutting a scene with
me and Danny pootie that came at the end
of the movie
and everybody loved it and it had like a
great joke in it but it was just
it just didn't quite make sense it just
didn't make sense for the plot do you
know what I mean everybody
a little bit and it also was like
too much CL yeah I guess it was probably
because once we wrote the role for Danny
and and once we got him on board to do
it then of course we wanted to like add
even more stuff for me yeah and have
like a sweet moment between our
characters
but like nothing is resolved yet in the
movie and you're like what they're like
leaving now in the hall so happy and
then in the next scene she's really
depressed like it just didn't make sense
yeah that's tough though when you gotta
cut it your best stuff it's tough for
them too because they have to be like we
cut the scene we shot it it felt so good
we all loved it you know yeah it's hard
to but it's also nice
I think for me
um it's nice being on the other side of
the camera and realizing how little of
that has to do with you right whereas
like early days acting you're like oh my
God they cut a lot of my scenes I guess
I
suck right you know and now you're like
oh it's not about me there's so much
other stuff going on totally totally but
you know we're artists so we still and
also yeah because also sometimes it
means like you're bad for sure exactly
but the dramedy the fact that it has to
I mean if it was a pure comedy we would
have left it right right yeah but you
know good point but it's also good to
know when to pull back right like you'd
rather leave people wanting more than
being like that was a really long comedy
right right
yes we're clocking in at like an hour 45
with credits which means it's actually
like an hour 40. I feel like over two
hours for a comedy I'm always a little
bummed I agree I agree because it tends
to fizzle out yes I feel like I'm that
way on the road if I do like I see
Comics we'll do like an hour 30
sometimes yeah yeah it's a [__] lot
I'll ask of an audience wow and an
opener an opener I keep my show minutes
my opener does 25 and I'll do usually
like an hour an hour five I'm like
that's like a 90 minute show same maybe
I'll do a little more sometimes if it's
like if I'm trying to work things in but
I do think like there's something to a
tight show because you're asking a lot
of a live audience yeah yeah definitely
to laugh over and over that's a lot of
energy I mean I guess it depends how
much stuff if you're like working stuff
out if you're sharing personal stuff I
think about like
um Mark Maron I feel like when he's on
the road
sorry I have a little Mimosa burp excuse
me you want another one yeah I'll go
over there okay for now no pressure yeah
um there's Molly in this one oh in that
case
um Anything Could Happen
I know I I haven't I've seen Marin
definitely live a few times when we work
together on globe and I love his comedy
I'm really excited for his new special
day it looks great it looks so good he
will talk about doing 90 minutes on the
road but maybe no opener oh yeah yeah
and Marin style of Comedy because it's
so personal and he's dipping into some
serious stuff I feel like that you I'm
more into the length is okay because it
feels like you're watching like a
one-man show yes yeah it's like the
Birbiglia exactly it's one step away
from the it's almost conversational it's
like we're all in this together it's
interactive and each of the audiences
maybe feel kind of special that they're
like oh I'm seeing some of the inner
workings and maybe not all this is gonna
make this special but I like hearing the
intimate stuff and this style is very
venti and and you know it's like I
connect to it a lot instead of like jewy
I love it even though I still feels like
a New Yorker to me even though oh yeah
well he cut his teeth here yeah he'll
always be yeah yeah yeah I think he grew
up in Arizona he grew up in Arizona but
he's got family in Jersey oh there you
go that counts yeah he has an East Coast
Vibe though really the pessimism
yeah cynical yeah angry but it's early
stuff his early album titles are so
funny they were all called like tickets
still available
yeah oh that's funny I didn't know that
do you do this is a dumb I'm not in
Hollywood question is this a myth or do
you guys really do the focus group like
the uh what do you call the test the
test show yeah yeah we did a couple test
screenings oh my god well because of
kovid you know we shot this in 2021 so
it was still sort of covety stuff and I
guess we only did a couple test
screenings for this movie and the first
one we did over Zoom you guys hate the
zoom okay I'm I Dave and I were separate
from one another so I was on location in
Columbia for a shoot Dave's in La the
audience doesn't know that we're on the
zoom also watching and everybody is
logged into Zoom so they're watching the
movie on their computer they like get
prepped beforehand and they're asked
like not to go to the bathroom and so
they'd have to really sit through the
movie
and we're watching them watching on
their computer
and it is the worst thing I have ever
experienced in my goddamn life that's
brutal let me tell you I've sat in on
test screenings before here's how people
watch a comedy in a test screening live
in the theater a joke happens and they
go
and on a zoom a joke happens and they go
nah we did Zoom shows we know right
there's like a nod maybe there's a nod
one woman like had a baby on her arm
it's like people look it's not even
saying anything about the movie it's
like the natural state of like think of
what you must look like when you're just
like watching something on your computer
right resting [__] face like you look
bored of course in the pajamas the
double chin they're eating they're
eating I'd rather watch Jeffrey tubing
that's a zoom for the first like 10
minutes of that I was texting Dave oh
thank you just being like this is the
worst experience of my life like why are
we even doing this and then I will say
also you have pages and pages of Zoom
people watching that you're scrolling
through eventually we just had to hone
in on a couple that were actually giving
great reactions you go like go to page
five there's a great woman in the upper
left corner
um Jesus I know and then we did one live
screening in LA but I couldn't be there
but Dave Dave said he enjoyed it and we
got and we actually did a little
additional uh shoot after doing those
screenings so like they are they're
helpful for sure I think for comedy it
is it's essential but helpful it's nice
to know what's track even for the story
to kind of know what's tracking and if
there's one thing that's not Landing you
know what I mean like you want to sink
The Landing at the end and like are
people connecting in the right way for
that so like it was helpful yeah your
whole job is our whole job is focus
grouping I mean you think about the road
and and when you see a comedy special
and it's a little loose and disjointed I
always think oh that's a comic who
didn't do the road yeah and then and
then you know run it through the mud so
I'm a big believer in focus group and
for let's take the air out let's find
those because also when you're sitting
with an audience you can tell when you
feel uncomfortable that you're like uh
oh this is a moment that's we're taking
too long right it's lagging like I can
read based on my own body chemistry that
something is awry yeah yeah that's
what's great about being married is the
sexual the body chemistry well the focus
group has been done sexually yeah so I
know what not to do what to do and then
you stop having sex but you know
you know not me
pull it up
yeah there's something about those Zoom
shows when we were doing during the
pandemic we'd have to you know do these
shows on Zoom they were the worst
experiences because of what you were
saying oh yeah and I remember one of
them feedback this is
sometimes they would type feedback oh
God I'd be doing sets one woman wrote uh
this new stuff is just horrible and then
uh and I was like well Heaven you know I
have to address that now so I'm like
going back I'm like yeah you can see it
in the chat and then someone else was
like [__] you [__] and then they start
going at each other and I'm just like uh
heckled in a zoom chat yeah sounds
terrible it's like performing on Reddit
yeah yeah that's like what I felt like I
was doing it was awful at least you can
hit mute I guess on the on the mean lady
but then everybody else sees it yeah no
no she wasn't she was typing it she
wasn't she wasn't oh yeah dude sorry no
no also there's a delay so it's like
three jokes to go they're like oh you
didn't oh you see you didn't like that
one horrible horrible experience and
there were those psycho Comics who would
say things like I actually like the Zoom
shows and I want to be like crazy quit
yes go do that don't don't do yeah be a
zoom cop yeah doing it for the wrong
reasons yeah and there's nothing worse
than bombing in your home yeah you know
you can bomb in a club and go home and
be like oh that was rough but now you're
at home now you're in the same room
after the computer is your whole house
yes the bomb stink on it exactly exactly
I have to find a new corner right do
your next set in on your next Zoom okay
I gotta change that background yeah you
know do you think you're gonna continue
you to make projects with your husband
definitely definitely it's
it's on so well we have in fact there's
a couple things that we have in the
works already that I won't say any more
about but like we kind of started
writing something recently and like
signing on to another thing to do
together so yeah we love it mostly
I mean this sounds really corny but
mostly we just like being around each
other we've spent a lot of time as
actors having to shoot things and be
apart for months at a time and that
sucks like when we make stuff together
we bring our two cats they're like our
own little traveling circus it's great
wow that's fun yeah and if you're riding
with someone you love and know you can
be honest if you're writing with someone
else it's kind of like oh I hate that
line but I don't want to get friction I
don't know actually I feel kind of two
ways about it because I've written two
movies with Jeff baina who's another
director who so we've had the same
Dynamic of like I've written with him
and then I star in the movie and he
directs it and we've actually made four
films together
and I feel the opposite like because
he's a friend of mine I'm more just like
oh you're gonna be super blunt with each
other about all this stuff like with my
husband I'm like oh should we just in
the way that we speak to each other
about notes except Dave always knows
because I'll be like because why do I
have to preface anything I don't like
with like honey I love you you're the
love of my life he's like just say it
what do you like about it right
sweetheart love of my life on page 47.
that is cool to have that though I mean
to you know
you just get to work together that's
another part of our life that like we're
never home true exactly it truly yeah
makes a difference just to be together
and be around each other and I think
also because
watch so
much together that we have the same
tastes and sensibilities like it's not
often that we're disagreeing on story
points or dialogue it is funny every so
often you'll get real
I don't know one of us gets like really
attached to a character right and me
I'll get all fired up she would never
say that he's like calm down that's fine
we can change it it's okay I believe
Dave wanted to cut that great booty joke
well geez I I we gotta we gotta wrap it
up put on the signal Big L you're you're
a bench this is great thank you this was
a lot of fun yeah watch uh Allison's new
movie someone that you used to know
somebody else Somebody That I Used to
Know I'm sorry on Amazon and uh yeah
it's it's uh it's really cool I mean
it's a and it's and you're great and uh
yeah the acting's great it's a great
story you gotta love it yeah full
frontal plus Merkin
so check it out check it out folks
awesome thank you and thanks for coming
in thanks you guys this is great all
right
are we what can you stop doing that for
a second all right
I'll be in uh Mark came and I had to
witness it it sucked uh Salt Lake City
this week we just yeah it was a sixth
show it's pretty much I think it's sold
out but it maybe not I don't know
whatever check it out uh Atlantic City
added a show Huntington
uh you know we added a show in Royal Oak
Michigan and Minneapolis I hope you you
come out uh Madison Milwaukee New Haven
added a fifth at the Wilbur so please
check that out that's coming uh Miami
Beach added a late show at a late show
in Orlando at a late show in Ponte vedro
whatever the hell that city is no
Jacksonville I think Atlanta
Charleston Durham Charlottesville
Norfolk Washington DC Late Show
Wilkes-Barre and Port Chester
samrill.com shows hey uh we added a
Friday show in Chicago at the Vic
theater for the uh special taping on
March 17th come on out we'll get as many
uh sets as we can and film all of them
uh Spokane comedy club uh just running
the [__] out of this set Skyline we got
eight sold out there oh my gosh yeah I'm
going all in Appleton 4 30 on Friday
then an eight then at 10 30. you're
doing a hooky show hook yes yes exactly
so uh come on up to that uh the funny
bone and who knows where Toledo oh yeah
not bragging one of those what else
really running it through the mud
laughing I got a great man see yeah
that's true that's good great meth and
barbecue yeah
I think that's kind of Toledo or Dayton
it's all the same but uh yeah 11
everybody live Oxnard right outside La
so come on out marketdomencomedy.com get
a ball about dig a cat get a cup get a
mug get a Stephanie and the Vega
catwhiskey.com folks can I plug the Matt
Ruby special that we haven't done that
go for it it's called substance it's on
Matt Ruby's YouTube page yeah we had
Matt Ruby do four sets over four weeks
he does four different substances he
does one show high one show drunk one
show on mushrooms and then one show
sober and we documented the whole thing
you cut out the part where he does one
show on auto erotic asphyxiation
so Matt Ruby on YouTube for that check
it out folks tell the folks anything
what's your grinder
you're going to be involved more next
week this wasn't a fair audition Shake
because uh with Allison here we'll we'll
do it for Neil yes for Neil Neil Brennan
yeah he's worthless
all right thanks folks comedy
[Music]
this woman doesn't look like I remember
her and I get down in the same way
[Music]
true